welcome to the UVM extension new farmer
project webinar creating products from
farm produce best practices for food
safety and regulations for value-added
food production in Vermont i'm jessie
schmidt and I work for the UVM extension
new farmer project I'm going to be
moderating this evening our presenter
tonight is lon de nada que she's a uvm
extension food safety specialist londa
grew up on a diversified farm in South
Dakota and after receiving her graduate
degrees worked internationally and food
safety for the food and agriculture
organization of the united nations londa
now works with value-added producers of
all sizes in Vermont to improve the
safety of their products and to assist
them with complying with state and
federal regulations welcome londa Thank
You Jesse and I have to say it's
webinars are great because I can you
know Jessie's in the office but I can be
home and give my baby a bath a few
minutes before and they can then give
the webinar after so I'm hopefully the
rest of you are somewhere comfortable as
well listening to this and hopefully
it's beneficial as well and I know that
a lot of people also listen we'll listen
to the recording as well I know I had a
few people asking about that so so ask
the questions because then the people
that are going to be listening to the
recording get some good feedback so so
I'll go ahead and get started the first
question I have actually I know Eric
mentioned that he's from out of state
let me see so if you can if you're from
Vermont can you check check the yes
button if those of you remember how to
do that okay see two so if you're from
out of state and you can click the no
button I guess
okay great all right well that's good to
just have a little bit of a little bit
of idea because so tonight I'm going to
talk i'm going to start out with talking
about food regulations for the state of
Vermont so so Eric and anybody that's
listening to the recording later you
know these rate you'll have to find out
from your state of course what exactly
the regulations are but but you know
some of the some of the same principles
might be true in other states but they
could also of course be different so so
I'll talk about our regulations here in
Vermont and then don't I see sandy is
from Vermont too so thank you so I'll
talk then i'll talk about federal
regulations and that applies to everyone
obviously and then and then i'll talk a
little about food safety best practices
and until you know this the webinar is
kind of geared for farmers that you know
you might be used to growing you know
fresh whole produce and selling
threshold produce and now you're wanting
to get into selling you know some sort
of value-added products and so i'll try
to kind of highlight the things that are
different between threshold produce and
in value added of course a lot of things
are the same too but there's some things
that will be different so and as Jeff
you mentioned that you have questions
throughout the presentation please feel
free to take feel free to write your
questions in the chat box and I can
answer them during our I can we might
like say to them to the end as well but
but if you have a question during the
presentation go ahead and write it down
before you forget so um so the first
thing that I want to start talking
talking about Ned's Jessie said I my
title is extension food safety
specialist and I studied public health
and so I'm always interested in a little
bit about statistics and how many people
actually are getting sick from foodborne
illness and and you know so you can see
the statistics listed there but the
thing is that these statistics are
really underreported
and the statistics are usually kind of
skewed a little bit towards towards
large-scale agriculture outbreaks from
large-scale agriculture because of the
way that you know reporting happens you
know if you have diarrhea or vomiting
you know not very many of us actually go
to the doctor when that happens I know I
had it a few weekends ago and I didn't
go as a doctor so first you have to go
to the doctors and the deck dress to
take a stool sample and then there has
to be enough people that have that same
strain of microorganism for them to be
able to say oh I wonder if this is you
know this is all from the same same
source and so there has to be a lot of
people that ate that food products for
it to actually show up as being a you
know foodborne disease outbreaks so so
all that to say that you know people
could get sick from from even
small-scale agriculture but it just
doesn't show up on the radar very
awesome because not as many people are
eating food made by you know produced by
a small local producer but but also I
want to make sure I emphasize that
products from small-scale producers can
be very safe and products from large
scale producers can be not safe or they
can be saved you know it all depends on
your practices so so that's the
important thing they really want to make
sure that everybody you know understand
and obviously those of you that are
listening obviously you think support
food safety is important otherwise you
wouldn't be spending your hour with us
tonight so so I'm preaching to the choir
so to say input borne illness in you
know if you're a generally a healthy
healthy adult you know you don't have
any major you know major health issues
generally speaking foodborne illness
probably probably isn't as big of a
concern for you but if you're selling to
any of these groups that are listed on
this slide you know to young people all
these children too
older people if you're selling to
nursing homes or maybe a senior center
or you know pregnant women pregnant
women are especially susceptible to
listeria and because the Syria can cross
the placenta and can even cause
miscarriage so you know of course
pregnant women by you know most products
and you know if you're selling to
hospitals or anywhere where there might
be sick people you know you really have
to be concerned with especially
concerned with food food safety and so I
since I've already mentioned my daughter
this is a picture of my daughter about a
year ago actually so she's quite a bit
older and has more hair here and this is
my grandma and when I when I think about
the importance of food safety I really
think about you know these two extremes
that I've you know that you really want
to make sure that your product is safe
for for those you know for those sort of
groups so to start out with you know
just generally speaking like if i want
to start making salsa i want to start
making jams and jellies ors bread or
something you know what what regulations
do i need to follow anyway so the first
question I always ask people is as well
if you're just selling in your state
then really it's the state regulations
that apply so you need to follow your
state regulations once you start selling
across state lines then you need to pay
attention to federal regulations and
when you're selling across state lines
there's no sighs exemptions no matter if
you're selling ten dollars worth of
products or a thousand dollars worth of
products you have to meet the federal
requirements I'll be talking about the
Food Safety Modernization Act and some
upcoming slides and that could really
change things in terms of you know if
people if you're only selling in state
you might have to might have to fall
this food safety modernization act so
that that's right now there's
rules are in the proposed rule stage and
that's from FDA so i'll talk about that
in a minute if you're selling your
products to grocery stores or coops
distributors they may have stricter
requirements then then the regulatory
requirements so you need to be sure to
check with them I know a lot of
specialty food producers you know their
goal is to sell to somebody like Whole
Foods someday and I mean that's it's
great you know it's a great market it's
a you know a great place to sell your
products but they do have really strict
requirements they because they have a
lot stricter requirements than the
government regulation so and even if
you're selling to distributors that are
selling to kind of larger specialty food
stores in larger cities such as in
Vermont I know I have I work with
someone that sells to the cells to a
distributor that distributes in to
specialty food stores in Boston and she
has to have a hasit plan and some
additional food safety plans just to be
able to sell them so just check with
your buyer to find out what their
requirements are again in the state of
Vermont to decide sure it's true in most
states if you're selling to restaurants
you have to follow the state regulation
there's no sighs exemptions because the
restaurant has to buy products only from
an approved source and so I'll talk in a
minute about these exemptions that are
in Vermont but but if you're selling
your restaurants those exemptions don't
apply to you and then if you're selling
to farmers market selling at farmers
markets there's not there's depending on
what you're selling if you're selling
prepared foods there are some additional
regulations and some temperatures that
you need to be concerned with I actually
did a webinar on this a week or two ago
and I have a number of fact sheets as
well on sorry regulations that best
practices for selling at farmer's
markets so i'll have a link to that
website at the end where you can find
more information on that okay so so i'm
going to start with talking about the
so as i said i'll start with the state
of Vermont and these are the Health
Department regulations and those of you
that just join I saw Michelle and rac1
joined I asked at the beginning and if
you don't mind if you're from the state
of Vermont there's a above your name
there's a checkbox and there's a green
check for yes and a red check for know
if you don't mind if you're from the
state of Vermont those of you that just
joined if you could click yes if you're
from Vermont and click the red mill if
you're not from Vermont just just so I
have an idea of who we're talking to so
racy is not from Vermont and that's fine
just just wanted to just wanted to check
maybe Michelle still finding it okay
that's fine all right so so back to the
Vermont regulations that again and
you're so you'll have to check in your
state exactly what el k Michelle is from
Vermont thank you so at you'll have to
check in your state what the regulations
are but in Vermont and you need to have
something called a food processors
license if you're doing you know jams
jellies salsa what else candy those sort
of things those off under the food
processors license however there is an
exemption that if you're selling less
okay Tracy's from New York thank you if
you're selling less than ten thousand
dollars worth of product per year you
don't need to have a food processors
license so so you don't you're not
regulated if you're selling less than
ten thousand dollars per year in the
state of Vermont and I know that New
York is stricter than that and i'm
guessing virginia is as well so so
vermont it has a little bit more lenient
in that regard and just to mention as
well if you are selling acidified foods
which would be salsas and if you're
selling pickles anything that that's
kind of a vegetable that's had some
vinegar added to it and you're selling
it shelf-stable those are considered
acidified foods and
you have to have what's called a
scheduled process for that so if you
have questions on the scheduling process
I can I can provide you with more
information on that so if you're selling
baked goods like you know breads cakes
etc then you need a bakery license again
there's an exemption on so you need that
license if you're selling more than
6,500 dollars per year so if you're just
doing a few farmers market selling you
know two hundred dollars or it will
hopefully a little more than that three
hundred four hundred dollars worth of
baked goods you don't need a license in
Vermont if you're selling juice then you
need to have a food processors license
again if you're selling more than ten
thousand dollars so if you're under that
you don't need a food processor license
for juice if you're selling juice out of
state you are required to have a hassle
plan which is a hazard analysis and
critical control points plan if you're
selling in in the state of Vermont they
just request that you have a hassett
plan that's not really a legal
requirement if you are and again half
the plans I can provide more information
on that if you're interested if you're
selling seafood then there's no sighs
exemption no matter how much you're
selling any sort of you know catching up
seafood and processing it or just
selling it you have to have a hasit plan
you have to follow the regulations okay
so all those regulations that I just
talked about there as well as the
restaurant inspection and then catering
licenses those are all under the Vermont
Vermont Department of Health then
switching over to the Vermont Agency of
Agriculture they regulate any dairy
products maple especially maple syrup
not so much other maple products that's
really under the Department of Health
eng also regulates pet food so now for
all those products there's no sighs
exemption so if you're selling twenty
dollars worth
you have to have a Dairy Dairy
inspection license and they have very
specific regulations and very in
particular it's a pretty stringent you
know you can do it you know it is
possible to be able to you know to be
able to build a facility on your farm
but but you know you SS stainless steel
etc so the agency of AG also regulates
meat and with meat if you if you're
selling a product that has more than
three percent meat or poultry by raw
ways that will fall under the Vermont
Agency of Agriculture so if you wanted
to make something like a meat pie you
know our chicken pot pie or you know
something like that and you wanted to
sell it you know frozen or refrigerated
or something at a grocery store that
would fall under the agency of
agricultural regulations and meat is
quite strict in their regulations you
have to have a half-foot plan it has to
be quite detailed again that's a hazard
analysis and critical control points
plan and you have to have you have daily
inspection and you again stainless steel
and so on so I know that some people you
know they feel like well they could just
you know do a little value added of
their own but it has to be done in an
inspected facility again you can you
know get the facility on your farm
inspected but it has to meet the
requirements so so if you're selling and
I think probably many of you know about
the poultry exemption if you're doing
less than a thousand birds per year on
your farm you can do it without
inspection and again I have some fact
sheets that talk more specifically about
the meet regulations to get more
information and also if you're a
producer and you're selling meets you
know depending on where you're selling
you have to have different licenses to
sell alright the agency of Agriculture
is also responsible for all labeling in
the state of Vermont so you
no like your jams and jellies and so on
they might be the safety that might be
inspected by health the labeling of them
is inspected by agriculture in the state
and i see your grace's question here so
I'll dress it while I well it's fresh in
my head do you know how similar these
rules and rules of the different
departments are for New York and
unfortunately i'm not exactly sure i do
know that you that New York's rules are
stricter than Vermont I don't think you
have any exemptions I think my
understanding is that you know if you're
selling any amounts of food products you
have to it has to be inspected there's
not those dollar exemptions one
difference to is the state of New York
does not have a state meat inspection
program like Vermont does so all of your
meat inspection would be under it would
be a USDA inspector which the the
requirements really are the same but the
thing is your inspector is a USDA
inspector rather than vacation Vermont
friendly Vermont guys that are that are
inspecting your meat product so son
Jesse just put a link that has all those
fact sheets I was referring to so yeah
and I don't know exactly the breakdown
between health and AG in New York I'm
afraid but but I can find out guys my
email will be at the end racy and if you
want to send me an email to remind me to
look I can I can look for you I can find
out ok so in the state of Vermont again
if you're wanting to apply for these
different state licenses that I talked
about rather than giving you all the
links in this webinar I just decided to
to refer you to this fact sheet that I
that I have on I'm 50g requirements for
Vermont food processors and in that fact
sheet there's you know
specific information on exactly what's
needed depending on what you're selling
and then there's information on how to
get the licenses from the health
department and from the agency of
Agriculture so that links that Jesse put
up earlier that you can click on that or
this is a shorter a little bit prettier
URL listed here and then you just click
on food safety for producers and
processors and then it's under
publications and then you could find
this back sheet and the other fact
sheets that I've been referring to ok so
now I'm going to go jump to the federal
level and so this would apply to to
everybody in all states across the u.s.
so so as I kind of indicated before USDA
inspection USDA would inspect meat and
poultry products so again it's the same
requirement as for Vermont the
three-percent meter poultry by rahway
anything greater than that is under USDA
inspection you're required to have a
half a plan and again there's no sighs
exemptions and just to mention too that
the Vermont meat inspection it's
considered equal to USDA inspection but
like I said the big difference is in my
mind the state inspection that the
inspectors are you know are a little bit
more a little bit more of an
education-focused rather than just a
regulatory focus where the USDA
inspectors are really having more of a
regulatory focus so and i'll get to
Michelle's question after i finish i'll
talk about the nutrition facts and we'll
get to your question um so for meat
there's a well relegates is a year old
now but a regular requirement now for
nutrition facts labeling on unmeet
products whole muscle Cutsem and
products with more than two ingredients
so again I have more information about
that in the late labeling fact sheet if
you're interested
so if you're planning to use the
Hardwick food hub hub sorry would you
need a license of your own the Hardwick
food hub a tent I don't know what kind
of product you're interested in they do
not you cannot do meet there but you can
do all the other products that I've
talked about well it they well centrally
to cheese there either necessarily but
but you can do you know salts and all
those sort of things you still have to
get a food product if you're doing you
know like jams or jellies or sauces
salsa etc you still have to have your
own food processors license because the
processors license is tied to you not
the facility however it's very easy to
get the license if you're using a
facility like the one in hardwick
because they're already you know the
facility is already passed inspection
and they know you know they know the
facility the inspector knows the
facility very well there they also have
FDA inspectors come through so you know
even if you're doing FDA that would be
fine so so yeah especially if you're
doing the in-state license you still
need to have your own license okay great
yep sauce barbecue sauce and ketchup yep
exactly so those sort of products would
all be would all be under the food
processors license and and again you
know it's really just almost a matter of
just sending in your money and it's like
hundred and something dollars per year
for the license and those products
probably would not require a scheduled
process depending on what kind of sauce
you're doing but the barbecue sauce and
ketchup would not require a scheduled
process okay so FDA regulations again
like I mentioned before there's no sighs
exemption so if you're selling you know
ten dollars worth of products across
state lines you have to have it you have
had you have to be registered with the
FDA and I'll talk about that in a minute
but you have to follow the after your
requirement so FDA really they do you
know processed foods and baked goods
like like I talked about earlier with
the Department of Health in Vermont FCA
also does dairy products maple syrup pet
food those are all things that are
regulated by the agency of Agriculture
here in Vermont but in in SGA they're
regulated by them sorry it's a federal
level of regulated by FDA I don't know
if anybody from New Hampshire is on but
i know that in New Hampshire dairy
products are regulated by the state
health department there and I'm not sure
about New York off top of my head FDA
also regulates seafood and fruit juice
and again they require you to have a
hash of plan alright so so they
mentioned if you're selling products out
of state then you have to you have to be
registered with the FDA and so the steps
for that our first you have to get your
licensing from the state of from the
appropriate Vermont Agency so even if
you're selling less than ten thousand
dollars worth of product in the state of
Vermont and you're exempt from the state
requirements if you're selling out of
state then you still have to get the
proper licensing from the state of
Vermont because that's the requirement
for FDA's to have the proper state
licensing first so with FDA well with
state of Vermont I kind of alluded to it
it's you know you have to pay a register
a licensing fee like 115 dollars or
something you have to you know send them
your money yearly with FDA it's free at
this point they're talking about having
user fees but at this point it's free
you just register online I didn't share
the link right now but I have it in that
fact sheets of food regulations actually
that I mentioned earlier you you're
required to reregister your facility
every two years it's in the fall of the
even-numbered years so 2014 in the fall
you should reregister the
just want to keep track of everyone keep
their list current the FDA might come
and inspect your facility once you
register with them on average I've heard
at national average FDA inspects your
facility once every approximately seven
years because there's so many food
processing facilities across the u.s. of
FDA's meant to inspect they just can't
get to everybody if you're considered a
higher risk facility like if you're
doing cheese or something they'll come a
lot more often than once every seven
years but you know no guarantees all
often will come so the FDA requirements
are you have to meet what's called the
Good Manufacturing Practices and I'll
tuck that's what I'm going to be talking
about in the next section are basically
good manufacturing practices kind of
best practices and you can find those
good manufacturing practices they're
available in the Code of Federal
Regulations title 21 part 110 and i
found FCA's URLs are really usually
really long so usually the best way to
find them rather than me giving you a
long URL is to just just google that and
you'll be able to find them there we go
okay so here's as I mentioned earlier
FDA has some proposed rules on what's
called the Food Safety Modernization Act
and there's a proposal on produce safety
as well as a proposed rule on what's
called preventative controls and
preventive controls is basically for
food processors these proposed rules
they're still in the comment period it
looks like the comment periods going to
be extended until like September which
is good to give us more time to look
through them and make some comments and
it'll be a few years before processors
would need to implement them however
I'll talk about the next slide it's a
good idea start thinking about it now
and to start moving towards moving
towards it whether you're going to be
exempt
not because we don't know what the final
rules are going to say in any case so
and you know anyway I have it the next
slide so i'll save it till the next
slide oh and the other thing i wanted to
mention to while i'm talking about it as
i mentioned at the beginning I wanted to
kind of highlight the differences a
little bit the differences between
produce safety and processing safety
with produce it's currently if you're
selling produce in the state of Vermont
there's absolutely no regulations for
you know the safety and produce that
you're selling your so if you're selling
you know your fresh tomatoes and carrots
and whatever at the farmers market fresh
whole you know tomatoes and carrots and
peppers and all those things the only
regulatory requirement is that the
product has not been exposed to flood
waters so so you know for produce
growers these proposed FDA rules are a
big game changer because you know they
haven't had regulations before people
doing value-added products you know
they're more used to regulations and you
know people are kind of aware that they
need to operate under regulations but
it's only that's a big difference
between you know if you're just selling
threshold produce versus selling
value-added products then there's a lot
more regulatory control so so on the
preventive controls proposed rules for
FDA the Food Safety Modernization Act
you can see there's a number of
exemptions and I apologize that it's
small font but it's just to kind of to
show that there's a lot of exemptions
but they're a little bit confusing and
so again I have a fact sheet that that
lists these in more detail and again
everyone different people kind of
interpret these proposed rules a little
bit differently and the thing is we
don't know exactly what's going to come
out in the final rules anyway but but at
this point it looks like small
processors would be exempt from
following the FDA
a revised requirements but but you'd
still have to follow the state
regulations one thing that's kind of
interesting is food hubs and people that
are better commingling produce from
multiple multiple growers they would
they would fall under the preventive
controls requirements if there's if
they're storing they're having
warehousing of the products you can see
that one's listed at the bottom there so
that's something important for food hubs
and anybody doing kind of you know
commingling of products from different
farms to keep in mind so if you are
going to be covered by the preventive
controls rules if you're not exempt from
them is what would you need you would
need to have a written food safety plan
which is similar to a half the plan I
touch I checked by half with a little
bit of hazard analysis and critical
control points so this preventive
controls plan would require you to do
monitoring and have records and
corrective actions for ya ok so this
preventive controls would require you to
monitor and have records and then
corrective action plans for your food
allergen controls and also for your
sanitation of your of your plants our of
your facility and then we clear recall
plans in hasit plans you have to go
through and identify where the biggest
hazards are and where you're most
critical control points are in your
process usually those are like in a
cooking step or a chilling step and then
you have to keep track you have to do
monitoring you know of the temperature
of the time you know and keep records of
that so that's in a typical hasit plan
but this preventive controls plan you
would have to have that as well as doing
monitoring and record
and so on for four items that are
typically in half the plans are
considered prerequisite programs so
those those food allergen controls and
sanitation so on so so preventive
controls are kind of language the FDA
uses used in the Food Safety
Modernization Act to talk about you know
that the places where you can best
prevent foodborne foodborne illness from
potentially resulting from your process
so it's super magic controls could be
cooking could be chillin it could also
be no sanitation plans that sort of
thing so the other thing with the
preventive controls rule is is that
they're updating the Good Manufacturing
Practices and I talked about those
earlier and we'll talk about them in a
minute the language will be updated a
little bit too but but it's not a major
update really but so those good
manufacturing practices and again that's
we'll talk about next are really
important whether you're covered by the
new requirements or not so and again if
you're not going to be covered you know
if you are going to be exempt from if
you're small enough producer if you're
if you're selling lower risk products
and you'd be exempt you know why why is
this important why do I keep talking
about it well here in Vermont the state
is talking about updating its
regulations and right now as I mentioned
the state of Vermont food processing
regulations are relatively loose
compared to other states so so they
really want to so they're talking about
updating those to have Heather be
stricter to kind of match the FDA's
requirements and you know whenever
there's a new regulation that comes into
place buyers very often also increase
their requirements so so the bar is kind
of
raised for everybody and then buyers
might also quite have stricter
requirements so so it's something again
to keep your eye on okay so if you're
exempt to the federal level how does
that differ from the state GMP so if you
are exempt from the Federal Food Safety
Modernization that specific
Modernization Act requirements then
basically you just have to follow the
state your state food safety regulations
and then in addition you have to make
sure that the name of the facility where
you process the product is on the label
which which is already really
essentially a requirement of labeling
and then you're supposed to notify the
FDA you know that you're that you're
operating under that small business
exemption but again we don't know
exactly how the final rules are going to
they're going to shake out so that's
that's what we that's what our
interpretation my interpretation is of
the proposed rules at this point does
that answer your question Tony or if if
you're looking for something else just
just maybe you can ask another question
too and I can clarify okay I'll I'll
keep going here is it Tony if you have
another question feel free to let me
know so some other steps to starting it
again and these might be a little bit
different in your state but generally
speaking these these are the steps I'm
sure in every state but this for sure in
Vermont you need to do these things so
you need to make sure that you check
with your town or city clerk for any
local zoning restrictions and any
licensing permitting that they might
have so just to make sure that you're
following their requirements it's
important to get a state food processors
license here in the state of Vermont
they require that you first talked to
the Department of device sorry the
Department
environmental conservation to check on
the wastewater facility or the
wastewater plan they don't necessarily
require that you have a new you don't
have to necessarily put in a new septic
system they might say you know you're
set with your current septic system is
fine but you do have to check with the
Department of Environmental Conservation
so that's something that's important
they do also require that you check with
the Department of Public Safety to make
sure that you're following the
electrical and fire and plumbing codes
so in order to get your state food
processors license you have to be in
compliance with the Dec and the
Department of Public Safety you also
need to check with the tax division
unfortunately I didn't say that but you
have to check out the tax division to
make sure you're doing your tax
requirements properly and then you
probably want to protect the name of
your business so you might want to
register it with a secretary of state to
protect your your awesome name that you
have for your business and this lake
down here has more has the lakes to all
these different websites that's the
department of health food and lodging
program website down there alright so
I've been talking about these best
practices and so now I'm going to kind
of going to finish up with this so again
these best practices are I mean
generally speaking this is what the
state of Vermont's food safety
requirements are for food processors and
also I guess I haven't listed down here
also this is generally speaking the
FDA's requirements so I'm going to talk
about these best practices kind of in
general terms but again if you look up
you know the FDA's good manufacturing
practices you can get the more specific
details and the state of Vermont to you
can find the specific regulations that
are required so these Good Manufacturing
Practices that's that's the terminology
that
da uses in in the regulations and
they're just they're the basic sanitary
and processing requirements that are
needed to just make sure that you're
processing safe foods so they're to me
they're just they're just best practices
you know they're a good idea for
everyone to follow whether you're exempt
it or not whether you're required to
meet regulations or not being on and
this is yeah like it says here this is
what's needed to to meet the current and
the future state and federal regulations
and this is both for USDA and FDA so if
you're doing anything under if you're
doing the meat processing the USDA also
requires that you follow good
manufacturing practices so again I've
been mentioning half the plans if you
are required to have a hasit plan that
has the plan requires that you have
these good manufacturing practices in
place so so they're really important
again I have a fact sheets that kind of
you know gives a nice or give a two-page
overview of good manufacturing practices
it might be helpful for you okay so to
start out with and in it and I just want
to emphasize to that a lot of these
things are probably common sense and in
again if you're kind of going from being
a you know produce grower or some sort
of a producer on the farm to doing food
processing a value-added processing a
lot of these things are kind of common
sense but and some of these things might
be things you're already doing but but
some might be a little bit different
there might be some new things to think
about with food processing so so again
I'll just talk about them so for
buildings and facilities when you're
doing food processing and value-added
processing you just want to make sure
that the grounds are free of weeds you
have the drainage you know the
facilities you have to have cleanable
surfaces good ventilation and lighting
you know the FDA these regulations they
don't really specify you know the
specific surface is that you need to
have just that they need to be cleanable
so that kind of makes it more general
again hand-washing facilities needed
water just kind of fold basic things I
guess your equipment and utensils you
have to make sure that you're using but
they're that they're of a sanitary
design again cleanable materials is
important you know make sure that its
food grade materials would grade
equipment that you're using and and then
the set the equipment is you know
installed and maintained that you can
easily clean underneath and behind this
isn't a great picture but you can see
that these carts are on wheels here and
so that you know they can be moved
easily I guess these are excels really
so then you can clean underneath the
shelf and below that are behind the
shelf more easily than if it was tied to
the ground personnel again this is this
is the same as if you're doing produce
raising threshold produce on your farm
you know you have to make sure that no
one is working sick you know think about
all the germs that are spread if you're
sneezing and just you know everybody has
to use good hygienic practices you're
doing value-added production you need to
wear hair restraints you know eating and
production again these are kind of
common-sense things okay that one area
that's kind of again kind of different
from just straight production to
value-added processing then you really
need to think about your raw material
and your your raw materials coming in
and your suppliers that you're using you
need to have some sort of a system in
place to make sure that your the raw
materials that are coming in and the
suppliers that you're using that you
know that that those materials are safe
because your product is only as good as
the ingredients that go into that and
then you know of course even if you're
buying produce from your own far are
using produce from your own farm i
should say you know you want to make
sure that that's the best quality safest
material that it medic that it can be um
so you know especially if you're getting
in
ingredients from from other places or
your own farm of course you want to have
some sort of inspection procedure you
know for incoming low as making sure
that everything is you know meeting the
your requirements and and and that
you're also just having good you know
good handling and good storage once
those ingredients get into your your
facility where you're doing your
processing okay so then when you're
actually processing you know we make
sure that your whatever ingredients are
coming in first that you're using those
first again kind of common sense and
then another important point here they
have a date and log incoming products I
think I have a slide later where I talk
about traceability and recall a lot
tracking that's something that's going
to be even more important under these
new new Food Safety Modernization Act
requirements so that's so it's really
important when you do get in ingredients
that you're dating dating those
ingredients in keeping track of what
ingredients are coming in and you know
just making sure that you're storing
your materials in a safe manner you know
making sure that that everything is as
good temperature control those are all
important okay sanitation is super
important as everybody ensures is is
well understood you you want to make
sure that your sanitizing everything
properly your washing everything and you
know to again once you get up to the
higher levels of food safety programs
and the stricter inspections you have to
have everything documented of what
you're doing for cleaning you know if
you're just using if you're just
operating under a you know just a state
of Vermont food processors license they
don't require you to document your your
sanitation standard operating procedures
but again once you start getting to the
higher levels you need to have that
documented it's just a matter of writing
down you know
step one take apart the mixer step to
spray it off step three you know wash it
with a brush that sort of thing but it's
also a good way you know if you have a
new employee you can you can show them
like okay here's our slps or standard
operating procedures for washing and
then that easy way to train people
another point I wanted to make is that
it's important to have make sure that
you're doing we should have a schedule
to kind of make sure that you're all
cleaning the coolers cleaning the
hallways these areas that you don't have
to clean every day but you do need to
make sure you clean them periodically
you know weekly monthly whatever is
appropriate for your facility okay
allergen control this is something
that's really important again under the
Food Safety Modernization Act but also
it's really important for because so
many people are sensitive to allergies
these days people are really aware of
allergens and you really want to make
sure that you're paying attention to
this because you're a lot of your
customers are so you can see the eight
major allergens that are listed these
are the ones that you're required by law
to list on your label and also to alpha
to monitor in your facility so here's
the main points for allergen control you
know make sure that your raw materials
are properly label to distort make sure
you know where your allergy and
container ingredients are in your
facility so just you know again kind of
some common sense things but but just
it's really important to keep to be
aware of allergens okay pest control
this is another another thing again
that's probably this is similar again to
you know if you're growing produce or if
you have animals obviously you don't
want pests everywhere because you know
they're not good for production and
they're not good for processing either
so you really want to just make sure you
prevent any of those pests from getting
into your facility but then you know if
you can't get them if they do
then you want to make sure they don't
have anything to eat while they're there
and then if you have to exterminate them
that's the last resort okay chemical
control it's also very important to make
sure that any cleaner sanitizers
lubricants all those things that are in
your facility that are not they're not
actually ingredients you want to make
sure that they are properly labeled that
they're stored you know away from the
food and that you're using them at the
right amount you know if you if you
think a cup of sanitizer is is good well
two cups is better that's unfortunately
not true if a cup is what's required you
use a cup that's it okay another program
that you have to think about is blast
control you know if you're sometimes you
know if you're using glass glass jars
you know for your packaging then it's
pretty obvious like oh I got to make
sure I I don't have breakage of Blass
but also you know everybody has light
bulbs almost over it because light bulbs
in their facility so you want to make
sure that those light bulbs are covered
and you want to make sure that you know
that that you know where all the glass
is in your facility and then you so you
can prevent any breakage from occurring
and even if you can't prevent the
breakage from occurring at least you can
detect it like you know where to look
for glass breakage I mean nobody wants
to have a piece of glass end up in there
beautiful sauce that they're selling to
people ok so I think this is the last
category of these sort of things i'll
talk about foreign materials again you
know nobody wants to see a nut your
bulbs or you know a person knife or you
know a piece of wood or a chunk of
plastic you know we don't want to see
those in our food products and see so
there's a lot of potential sources you
can see them all listed here how these
pharma shows can
into your food product so in order to
control them you want to make sure that
you're doing good visual inspection when
you're receiving the products to
receiving the raw material sorry that
you don't have you know chunks of wood
and your carrots or something like that
or big rocks or something and you know
when you're adding ingredients to the
mixer make sure that you're watching
that there's no you know chunks of stray
things coming in and just practicing you
know good hygiene and good housekeeping
those are all important things but just
things to keep in mind and like you've
been having a pen in your coat pocket
your if it's a lab coat if you lean over
that pen could fall in and you don't
want to penn ending up in your products
okay i mentioned earlier traceability
and recall again this is something
that's really of growing importance and
it's important that you know you need to
know where your ingredients came from
you need to know who you bought them
from you need to know which ingredients
went into every batch of your product
and then you need to know where your
products are going because you know we
hope that everybody is producing say
product that you never have to issue a
recall but if you do you need to know
where your products are going and what
could also happen to and maybe more more
likely is that one of the ingredients
that you use like maybe your salt or
maybe your you know whatever is your
starter culture maybe that's recalled
and then you have to know what batches
thats all to that starter culture went
into so that you can recall that final
product if you need to so you need to
have an accurate documentation of your
receiving of your ingredients of your
lot coding systems you have to know you
have to document your distribution where
your products are going and I can I can
provide you with
examples of this receiving log if you're
interested and here's that here is the
distribution record example and Jesse
your question is an excellent question
you asked about if there's any good
software programs that help with lot
tracking are they affordable actually
thank you for prompting that because the
Vermont farm viability program is
actually sponsoring a project right now
on a lot tracking and they did a survey
I'm not tracking to find out what people
are using and and they're looking into
and the guy's name is Stan Ward that's
organizing it and he's also looking into
all the different like software programs
that are available there's a number of
them available you just told me today I
think that's that we found like 27
different programs or something
unfortunately all those well some of
them are definitely more affordable than
others for those lot tracking software
and so one of the outcomes of that
project is intended to intended to make
sure that there's you know hopefully a
provision of a affordable and easy to
use and you know appropriate to scale
lot tracking system so yeah great
question and yeah you can buy really
expensive programs to Tony yeah link is
that a link for the those records that i
was talking about the distribution and
receiving records I can't send I can
send a link for those if you're
interested okay so the other
prerequisite programs wrapping up here
you know we hope that nobody will have
any complaints because the you know of
course your products are going to be
great
but it's if there is a if you if you do
ever get complaints you really need to
log them and track them that way you can
find out you know if you need to make
any corrections to your system labeling
is also really important i mentioned
labeling a little bit in the
presentation i do have a fact sheet
again on labeling and i do workshops and
so on and labeling as well so that's
important too and then the food defence
and security prevention of intentional
contamination that's also something
that's kind of growing importance and so
yeah i'll follow both of the slides and
i'll address Tony's question there so
this additional information so you can
see I have a number so there's some
upcoming trainings and then these fact
sheets that have been talking about the
number of links to different places are
available here from this URL that's
listed Jesse's also listed in the chat
box a few times then I just want to
mention Vermont has a food safety task
force that we're trying to get more
quickly to information from all
different aspects of vermont in one
place there's my contact details so if
you have any specific questions or any
information that you want me to be sure
to provide you you can send me an email
or give me a call and tony a link for
the software for the tracking at this
point like i said there's like twenty
seven different software systems so I
don't have I don't have all those links
readily available but I can send you
again if you send me an email i can send
you at least this the report of the slot
tracking project that's going on and and
hopefully the final product the final
results of the project will be out soon
as and then we'll
have then we'll have that information
more readily available as i can give you
the guy's name is doing that project too
and he can probably give you all those
links pretty easily so with that I'm
sorry I see it's two minutes to eight
but I'm happy to take any questions in
the remaining time that we have londa
thank you so much you covered such a
wealth of information here in a short
period of time and it's nice to have
this all in one place now so this
recording is going to be available on
the new farmer project website as as
well as a PDF of this presentation so
you can go back and reference it later
that should take about usually takes
about a week to get up on our website
and if there are any final questions go
ahead and type them in otherwise thank
you all for joining us this evening and
londa thank you so much for taking the
time to be with us looks like there's
one question yeah and are you too many
colleagues in New York londa that are
working on this in a similar type wine
yeah yeah Cornell actually I go to I
called Cornell quite a bit for questions
there Cornell is great especially on
scheduled process stuff like so if
you're doing canned foods they're
they're great on that sort of thing it's
the Cornell food venture center
Elizabeth Sullivan and the person i
always ask questions too they don't do
quite as much in maybe like farmer's
market food safety that sort of thing
but but yeah they have a lot of great
expertise there all right great well I
hope that you will take a minute to give
us some feedback and Lante have a good
evening thanks again and we will be
having our next webinar the last Tuesday
in May seven pm and it's going to be
focused on fencing so please join us for
that if you are interested have a good
night everybody
you